Hey,
I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich
and we are talking on radio lab about
things stochastic like going
flips in lottery tickets.
Let's just push this whole argument
another step forward if we may,
which mean let's talk about human
beings. Would it surprise you Jen,
if I told you that on the
subject of predictability,
humans and coins are kind of similar.
It wouldn't surprise me
because I wouldn't believe it.
You wouldn't believe it if I made
you an argument. So powerful.
So phishing that you will be falling
back on your buck in surprise and staring
at me with a kind of simple admiration
that you rarely have because here it is.
It is. I'm going to talk to you
about basketball, basketball.
That is a sport where people have a,
what do you know about basketball?
I need basketball is a game of skill.
Don't even try and pretend is like
random forces like coin flip. Nope, nope,
nope. Let me make you an argument.
Let me make you an argument.
Let's just take to make
it really interesting.
The most skilled basketball
team ever. For example,
you could take a look at the 82 to 83 76
no, Philadelphia, 76 years.
Maurice Cheeks. Quiet.
No regular on our show. It's
one of the best NBA teams home.
All the cheat sheets.
The doctor Jake's whooping
underneath putting it up in here. So,
so during the playoff, isn't it the
76 or it was all incredibly hot.
Take my man, Andrew,
Tony during this run he
was eating sometimes Andrew
tooney would make five shots
in a row. He would be
considered hot. That's the deal.
Angela hits his mark once. It's his
mark twice. It doesn't like three times.
Now I'm going to pass them
cause he's obviously hot.
The basket looks to him that it's the
size of a soccer goal. He's golden.
He's got the gods on his.
We're talking about them. We're,
because in this situation you'd have
to agree to the Andrew. Tony was hot,
right? Yes, that's the word. So what
exactly do you mean when you say hot?
Why are you asking me? [inaudible] he's,
he's making a bunch of shots in a row.
And if you're on his team and
you're coming down the court,
you pass the ball to Andrew because he's
on a roll with the fan assumes is that
after five shots you'd be more
likely to make a six shot.
That to me just seems
like like a common sense.
If he's waking lots of buckets,
of course you're going to pass the
to if did the players assume this?
Obviously if they're going to pay.
The players all believe this coaches
believed this too. The coaches believe it,
so it actually dictates
the plays they call.
Everyone assumes it to be true that the
hot end is a real thing and dictates the
flow of basketball games. Thank you
Jenna Bat, the hot hand doesn't exist.
You could just get,
you just went through this whole rigmarole
about the six years being hot. Yeah.
While they were a great team,
but a lot of scientists have looked at
this question of hotness and sports and
in fact there's a couple of scientists
who actually looked at all the maid shots
and the Ms Shots of this
76 [inaudible] team.
And when they looked directly at the
numbers, emotions aside, just the data,
here's what they found. At the very
moment you think you're hottest,
you're actually freezing cold.
Wait, that can't be right.
Some of these percentages are
pretty damning. Take Andrew. Johnny.
During the regular season,
Tony made 46% of his shot,
46% after hitting three shots in a
row, which means he's in the zone.
He's totally there.
His field goal percentage drops
to 34% so that is what I'm saying.
That's what I'm telling
you Jenn at boom red.
And the reason seems to be is that Andrew
knows he's hot or he thinks he's hot,
so he's taking less responsible
shots. He's taking, you know,
the three-point jumper from way beyond
the art and he assumes his streak will
somehow save him.
Cannot be because Johnny UFCU,
you've been the basketball games.
You see what happens, guy makes three
shots in a row. The crowd gets up.
Suddenly there's an electricity in the
air. Every time the guy gets the ball,
everyone stands up and anticipation.
You're telling me that's all a
figment of our collective imagination.
It is a figment of our
collective imaginations and it's,
and it's especially a figment of the
way we kind of calculate streaks.
The reason Andrew seems so
hot is because he makes three.
This is the fourth makes the fifth.
This is the sixth makes the seventh
and eighth. It's really rewrite
that essentially random process. This,
this mixture of makes and misses.
We rewrite it in terms of, oh, it's
a street. Once we think he's hot,
we tend to edit what actually happens
to kind of preserve that sense of the
street. Ah, okay. Don't believe Jonah.
What about Jay Kohler, our statistician
from, uh, Arizona state DV.
I've listened to him. No
reason to think even if,
whether he missed seven in a row or made
seven or o or made three of his last
four, I don't really care.
I know that he's a machine.
He's like a 52% shooting machine or
whatever his number is. No, but he's,
and he's a, he's not a machine though.
He's sleazy. He's like person with,
with uh, with confidence that ebbs
and flows. There's a different,
there's got to be a difference
there. I agree with you. You,
you've just described the psychological
theory that makes the hot hand beliefs
so compelling and so hard
to get rid of with data,
but it just doesn't matter whether
the player made three or miss three,
their probability of
making that fourth shot,
that next one is pretty
much the same. This is very,
very depressing.
Essentially what you're saying is that
basketball players are like coins. Coins.
Yes.
[inaudible]
the fact is, Jed,
you are Koby Bryant even is more like
a coin than any of us had neared to
imagine. Colby now has a
pattern. In his case it's what,
50 60 40 on any given night with
Kirby, you think, oh, this is,
he's back.
Tyco always doing because he's just
having another night of his very 60,
40 life. And that's just the way it
plays out. Even on a shot by shot basis,
you're saying, yeah, each shot seems
to be kind of a random event. Exactly.
Are you, are you willing to concede
this statistically this is not yet.
It's so counterintuitive. It,
I still as a basketball fan,
I was just watching game of the night
saying pastor cobia cause he's clearly
hot. Um, the only exception
to this whole whole
literature of streakiness
is uh, is, is a hockey,
no, is
this sport no one cared about? Is it,
is it Joe Dimaggio's hitting streak
where he eats for 42 games in a row?
I've gotten the book somewhere.
Actually Jody Maggio's heady
streak was 56 games. 56. Yeah.
So Joe Dimaggio is just about the only
Adler you can find in professional
sports. Only real hero. Yep.
Well at least I got Joe
[inaudible].
You know what yet one reason you have
trouble, I think more than Trello still,
you're not the only person who
is a person of pattern and habit.
We all are pattern rules.
The brain. Here's another story.
This is again from Joan Alara,
but this one is about a woman,
I believe. Her name is Ann.
Oh, name Khan. Stabber.
I live in a small country town where
most people know that the people
n was a high school English teacher. Yeah.
Tough for 31 years now lives
in West Virginia. Wait,
can you wait the Smith, there's someone
at my door, I'm sorry. They know that.
And then of course of course,
and most an upstanding citizen went to
church every Sunday was just one of those
people who makes the world go
round. It makes the world go round.
I'm sorry. Not at all.
Anyway,
in 1991 I would go to the grocery store
and on the occasions I wrote a check for
my groceries that was
say, gosh, you're shaky.
And she says, she began to
notice that her hands would to,
oh, are you all right?
But a this something maybe it was
because of working hard and trying to get
everything then
and it got particularly bad when she
said she was just walking in the mall.
Doing some shopping
and,
and it was balanced self walking and
I was like a stepped off a staff that
wasn't there you,
it was the first full
body tremor. She fell.
And then my husband was a doctor and they
sent me to a neurologist who day lists
me with Parkinson's.
Well, how old, how old is she by the way?
She was at that point in her early
fifties. What is Parkinson's?
Parkinson's is the death of dopamine
neurons in the back of your brain,
in the part of your brain
that controls bodily movement.
And so when these neurons die,
the end result is first a shaking hand
and the loss of feeling and the loss of
movement. And then of course the tremors
get worse and worse. Right. Anyway,
well the doctor diagnosed with Parkinson's
and he gives her a drug called the
[inaudible]
quip was a new medicine, 1992.
It's a pseudo dopamine in basically
mimics dopamine and the synapse of the
cells.
And it was like a miracle drug for me.
[inaudible]
her tremors disappear,
her symptoms disappeared.
So she's cured or uh,
if you looked at her on Requip
years after she had Parkinson's,
you wouldn't notice anything.
She would seem symptom free.
So about seven or eight
years ago by all the wild,
they're upping the doses to
compensate for the cell loss.
It's still taking place in the early years
of 2000 and something sort of unusual
happened to Anne.
Some friends of mine had gone to Las
Vegas every year for them basketball
tournament, the Phantom
for type thing. And um,
they asked would a,
I took a with them and I said yes I would.
So she went to watch basketball,
but as often happens in Vegas,
one afternoon she and her friends
found themselves in a casino.
Had you ever gambled before
this trip to Las Vegas?
Nah,
I was raised in a household
that was fairly religious
and we considered gambling
a sin.
But as she stood there
in the Casino in Vegas,
she had this inexplicably urge
to go to the slot machines,
the frozen quinces and cars
and cherries and the lemon.
The Shubin will span and
see what the pictures did.
I've never taken any drags side
or anything to compared to bit,
it was like a high,
that was sort of the beginning of a
um, and then, and then when she
comes back to West Virginia,
yeah. It can wait to get to a
machine that really want to buy.
She discovers the dog racing tracks. Good
spot that 15 miles away from my house.
Yeah. Seven 30 be there when they
open and that's, and
that's where she would go.
And they had a wider
sort of slot machines.
Are you
if I had the money at play all day
from seven to three 30
in the morning. Wow. Um,
and then she would go home and play
slots. The computer on her computer.
I'm not even sure
for money.
Just for the sheer visceral thrill.
Oh, apply that now. That's the night.
Seven 30 then it's morning. I'll be back
the joint without any sleep at all.
No sleep. And she could keep it
up for several days in a row.
It's the beginning of my gambling.
I'd wake up in the night and just
screaming out, Oh God, what am I doing?
Help me save me. But
eventually I became too hard.
Our did I guess, see even
pay attention to them.
Her credit cards are all maxed out.
So my mother's silver, so my silverware,
things that should've been my son's
heirlooms though from the safety deposit.
She steals quarters from her grandkids,
steals quarters from her grandkids.
Yeah.
Yeah. Anything like that around the house.
I thought I could get money
out of everyone who knows
her as watching her life
fall apart. Right. House was filthy,
dirty and math have haven't
take time to even wash dishes.
She lives on peanut butter. It doesn't
have any crackers or bread or anything.
This had been a better, um,
because that's all she can afford and
still leave as much money as possible for
the slots.
Even when I be at church at thing was
so many more minutes or so many more
hours. I can get gamble. Her husband
eventually leaves her. I mean,
I loved my son, but I got divorced.
There's just no decision.
Everything is gambling.
One of the neat things about gambling
he is, he can do it by yourself.
How much money did you lose during those
years, if, if you don't mind me asking,
I lost at least $300,000.
300,000 now,
which to her is, is all your life savings
and it's one quarter at a time. Yeah.
That's the surreal part.
Bad
dread. Several things. I
went to a Rehab facility,
uh, father, I told judge rice
in a really, they just, Huh.
So that is, I would say bad days,
but shoot me for bad for the, the,
he wouldn't approve of this.
He wouldn't be so disappointed me
bed.
See at is getting stop.
[inaudible]
let me pause here for a second, Jeff. Uh,
I want to just take a moment to try to
figure out what exactly is happening to
and yeah, why can't she stop? Yeah.
It turns out there may be an
explanation if you look into her brain.
Well remember earlier we talked about a
little chemical called dopamine and how
she didn't have enough
dopamine in her brain.
So that was giving her some kind of
movement trouble. The Parkinson's. Right.
It also turns out to be the case that
anytime you do something that makes you
feel good, your Brene spurts out dopamine.
For years,
that's how scientists saw dope mean as
as the neurotransmitter of pleasure,
the neurotransmitter of sex,
drugs and rock and roll.
But you said earlier that dopamine
has to do with movement. Well,
what is the ultimate purpose of movement?
From the perspective of evolution,
it's to get you to food. It's to get
you to sex. It's to get you to a reward.
So that's why the same circuits, the
same chemical that controls motivation,
that controls what you want,
also controls movement.
But if it turned out it was a little
more complicated than that. In the,
in the mid 1970s guy named Wolfram Schultz
decided to take a much closer look.
Man, he has subjects. It
was a monkey.
So he would put these very thin
needles that can record the activity of
individual Dokeman neurons
in the monkey brain.
And they put the monkey in the room and
then every day they would walk down the
hall to the room. The hunky
was, it opened the door. Hello,
monkey flip on the light. They give
the monkey some juice. You go monkey.
And then when the monkey sip the juice
[inaudible]
let me happy monkey. Right.
But then comes a surprise.
He soon discovered something
very odd about these neurons
as the juiced this monkey.
Hey. Hello. Monkey monkey.
Danielle. Monkey. Dannon,
monkey. The squirt dopamine,
which they were always measuring in the
monkey's brain seem to move forward in
time. What do you mean? Well,
at first the dopamine hit when the
monkey took the sip juice. Hello Monkey.
But after awhile the monkey
got the dopamine hit when
they entered the room and
switched on the light and a
monkey. After a few more times,
the dopamine hit when the researchers
feet could be heard walking down the hall.
You see what's happening here?
Hello, monkey. Um, not really.
You'd have to bring it home for a
little bit and I'll, I'll do it again.
What the monkey is trying to do is piece
together the sequence of events that
inevitably lead to juice. Exactly.
That's what these cells do.
They try to predict reward.
Oh, so this isn't just about
movement or about feeling good.
It's about finding the pattern of the
thing that makes you feel good. Yeah,
it's pattern find. Oh, this
is pure pattern recognition.
This is essentially how your brain makes
sense of reality in some very primitive
sense. It parses reality
in terms of rewards.
So this is how you get more
food in the wild is you.
You can see the reward
before anyone else can.
So we're talking about like
basic survival stuff here.
There's one other wrinkle though,
method Dokeman system that makes casinos
and slot machines so tantalizing,
which is that these cells
are also programmed to be
very sensitive to surprising
rewards. So this seems to be,
most scientists speculate that the seems
to be your brain's way of telling you
pay attention. You just got something
for free. This must be good.
Sit here in this nice comfy velvet
chair and try to figure out this reward.
So now imagine Anne sitting
there at the slot machine.
She pushes the button
on the machine machine
[inaudible]
and sirens and bells go off
coins claim and inside her head
[inaudible]
her dopamine. You're on there
saying this is wonderful,
but now how did this happen?
Where did this big Roy come from?
What did you do this time? Why
are you so happy? All of a sudden
searching for something they had frozen.
The number of cherries that she had just
before was it that this machine had 13
hits and this was the 14th dot. I can
tell you it has all kinds of pattern,
like things. It has bells, it has white,
but the problem is is that there is no
pattern defined. There is no pattern.
It's inherently random. It's
inherently unpredictable.
And while the rest of us might just,
you know, give up and walk away, God,
I just wasted a hundred
bucks on this stupid machine.
I should go get lunch
and can't go to lunch.
Her dopamine system is
too powerful, too potent,
oh cause of that drug she's taking,
right? It keeps surging and surging,
forcing her neurons to fight,
fight hard to find a pattern.
That's what's gripping her.
Her brain is intoxicated
at the possibility that it
will learn how to succeed,
that it will crack and uncrackable
code thought I was good at soften and
machines. In fact, she told me a
story about she would go to buy milk,
um,
and then spend the next 12 hours with
the milk rotting next to her is she puts
quarter after quarter after
quarter into this machine.
Were you surprised when you learn that
the medication might be responsible for
your gambling addiction?
I mean, as some was said to me,
this mezzo causes compulsive
gambling. I thought they're crazy.
It's just at that time where the first
studies come out showing that this is
actually a common side effect of Brexit.
Really. So there were other ans
appearing in other places. Same deal.
Absolutely.
Basically after my neurologist
sent me off the rig, clear,
her compulsion disappeared
instantaneously, almost
immediately. That fast. Well,
within a weekend say wow, it was gone.
Evan gambled for nearly three years.
Did her Parkinson's return. Yeah,
I have dreamers lot worse
recently. Again, like king,
I have trouble walking
and he's so awkward.
So the price of not being a gambling
addict is living with debilitating
Parkinsonian symptoms. That last
son, let me finish about my son,
and I told him after the
clique game plan, I said, son,
so the things that belong to you that you,
these said, mom, they're just
this really great debut bag. [inaudible].